YOU KNOW, MY FATHER ALWAYS TOLD
ME IT'S NOT HOW YOU START, IT'S
HOW YOU FINISH, AND NOW WE NEED
TO FINISH STRONG FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW THE SON OF A FIREMAN
AND A GRANDCHILD OF IMMIGRANTS
CAN RISE TO THE HIGHEST POSITION
TO THE MOST IMPORTANT
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND IF MY COLLEAGUE, HAKEEM
JEFFRIES, WITH HIS LIFE STORY
CAN RISE TO LEAD HIS PARTY, THEN
OPPORTUNITY IN DEMOCRACY STILL
THRIVE IN AMERICA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO LEADER JEFFRIES, THERE WILL
BE TIMES WE AGREE, MANY TIMES WE
WILL DIFFER.
I PROMISE OUR DEBATES WILL BE
PASSIONATE, BUT THEY WILL NEVER
BE PERSONAL.
THAT'S MY COMMITMENT TO YOU.
AND NOW THE HARD WORK BEGINS.
WHAT WE DO HERE TODAY NEXT WEEK,
NEXT MONTH, NEXT YEAR WILL SET
THE TONE FOR EVERYTHING THAT
FOLLOWS.
TONIGHT I WANT TO TALK DIRECTLY
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AS SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE MY
ULTIMATE RESPONSIBILITY IS NOT
TO MY PARTY, MY CONFERENCE, OR
EVEN OUR CONGRESS.
MY RESPONSIBILITY, OUR
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO OUR
COUNTRY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TWO MONTHS AGO YOU VOTED FOR A
NEW DIRECTION FOR OUR COUNTRY.
YOU EMBRACED OUR COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA, AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP OUR COMMITMENT TO YOU.
IT'S A COMMITMENT TO FOR AN
ECONOMY THAT'S STRONG, WHERE YOU
CAN FILL UP YOUR TANK OF GAS AND
FEED YOUR FAMILY, WHERE
PAYCHECKS GROW AND NOT SHRINK.
IT'S A COMMITMENT FOR A NATION
THAT'S SAFE, WHERE COMMUNITIES
ARE PROTECTED, LAW ENFORCEMENT
IS RESPECTED, AND CRIMINALS AR
E
PROSECUTED.
A COMMITMENT FOR THE FUTURE
THAT'S BUILT ON FREEDOM WHERE
CHILDREN COME FIRST AND ARE
TAUGHT TO DREAM BIG BECAUSE IN
AMERICA DREAMS CAN STILL COME
TRUE.
A COMMITMENT FOR A GOVERNMENT
THAT IS HELD ACCOUNTABLE, WHERE
AMERICANS GET THE ANSWERS THEY
WANT, NEED, AND DESERVE.
OUR SYSTEM IS BUILT ON CHECKS
AND BALANCES.
IT'S TIME FOR US TO BE A CHECK
AND PROVIDE SOME BALANCE FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICIES.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
THAN MAKING IT POSSIBLE FOR
AMERICAN FAMILIES TO LIVE AND
ENJOY THE LIVES THEY DESERVE.
THAT IS WHY WE COMMIT TO STOP
WASTEFUL WASHINGTON SPENDING, TO
LOWER THE PRICE OF GROCERIES,
GAS, CARS, HOUSING, AND STOP THE
RISING NATIONAL DEBT.
WE PLEDGE TO CUT THE REGULATORY
BURDEN, LOWER ENERGY COSTS FOR
FAMILIES, AND CREATE GOOD PAYING
JOBS FOR WORKERS BY UNLEASHING
RELIABLE, ABUNDANT AMERICAN-MADE
ENERGY.
I KNOW THE NIGHT IS LATE, BUT
WHEN WE COME BACK OUR VERY FIRST
BILL WILL REPEAL THE FUNDING FOR
87,000 --
[ APPLAUSE ]
YOU SEE, WE BELIEVE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD BE TO HELP YOU, NOT GO
AFTER YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS BILLS TO FIX
THE NATION'S ERRANT CHALLENGES,
FROM WIDE OPEN SOUTHERN BORDERS,
TO AMERICA'S ENERGY POLICIES TO
WOKE INDOCTRINATION IN OUR
SCHOOLS.
WE'LL ALSO ADDRESS AMERICA'S
LONG-TERM CHALLENGES, THE DEBT
AND THE RISE OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
CONGRESS MUST SPEAK WITH ONE
VOICE ON BOTH OF THESE ISSUES.
THIS IS WHY WE'LL END WASTEFUL
WASHINGTON SPENDING.
FROM NOW ON IF A FEDERAL
BUREAUCRAT WANTS TO SPEND IT,
THEY WILL COME BEFORE US TO
DEFEND IT.
AS FOR THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
PARTY, WE WILL CREATE A
BIPARTISAN SELECT COMMITTEE ON
CHINA TO INVESTIGATE HOW TO
BRING BACK THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS THAT WENT TO
CHINA, AND THEN WE WILL WIN THIS
ECONOMIC COMPETITION.
NOW, SPEAKING OF COMMITTEES, WE
WILL HOLD THE SWAMP ACCOUNTABLE,
FROM THE WITHDRAWAL OF
AFGHANISTAN TO THE ORIGINS OF
COVID AND TO THE WEAPONIZATION
OF THE FBI.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR, WE WILL
USE THE POWER OF THE PURSE AND
THE POWER OF THE SUBPOENA TO GET
THE JOB DONE.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL
AGREE UPON.
WE WILL STAND UP AND SPEAK OUT
FOR THE BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY,
THE HARDWORKING TAXPAYER.
IT'S NIGHTTIME HERE IN
WASHINGTON, BUT IN SOME WAYS
IT'S ALSO LIKE A NEW BEGINNING,
A FRESH START.
MY FRIENDS, THIS CHAMBER IS NOW
FULLY OPEN FOR ALL AMERICANS
[ APPLAUSE ]
I WANT TO GIVE ALL AMERICANS A
PERSONAL INVITATION.
YOU ARE WELCOME TO SEE THIS BODY
AT WORK.
NO LONGER WILL THE DOORS BE
CLOSED, BUT THE DEBATES WILL BE
OPEN FOR YOU TO WITNESS WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE PEOPLES HOUSE.
FROM THE COMMITTEE ROOMS TO THIS
FLOOR, WE COMMIT TO PURSUE THE
TRUTH PASSIONATELY AND EMBRACE
DEBATE.
NO MORE ONE-SIDED INQUIRIES.
COMPETING IDEAS WILL BE PUT TO
THE TEST ENPUBLIC SO THAT THE
BEST IDEAS WIN.
BUT WE ALSO PLEDGE TO BRING
CONGRESS TO THE PEOPLE BECAUSE
ANSWERS HAVE NOT AND WILL NOT
ALWAYS BE FOUND IN WASHINGTON.
THAT'S WHY ONE OF OUR VERY FIRST
HEARINGS WILL BE HELD ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
NO MORE IGNORING A CRISIS FOR
SAFETY AND SOVEREIGNTY.
WE MUST SECURE OUR BORDER.
WE MUST GET AMERICA BACK ON
TRACK.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE TO MY FAMILY
HERE AND AT HOME, TO JUDY,
MEGAN, CONNOR, EMILY, MY BROTHER
MARK, EMILY, ZACK, AND, YES, MY
MOM BERT, I AM WHERE I AM
BECAUSE YOU ARE WHO YOU ARE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YOU CAN STAND.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY
CONSTITUENTS FROM CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL VALLEY AND ESPECIALLY MY
HOMETOWN OF BAKERSVILLE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH MUSIC BUT AS -- SINGS HOW
MANY OF YOU THAT SIT AND JUDGE
ME HAVE EVER WALKED THE STREETS
OF BAKERSFIELD.
WELL, I'VE WALKED THOSE STREETS
MY ENTIRE LIFE.
I KNOW IT'S PEOPLE.
THEY'RE HARDWORKING AND
RELENTLESS, OPTIMISTIC ABOUT OUR
FUTURE.
AND I'M VERY HONORED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT THEM.
I AM THE SON OF A FIREFIGHTER.
I SAW FIRST-HAND WHAT IT MEANS
TO HAVE HARDWORK, LEADERSHIP AND
SERVICE TO OTHERS.
IT CAN CHANGE PEOPLES LIVES, AND
THAT IS EXACTLY WHY WE ARE HERE
TODAY, TO SERVE YOU, THE PEOPLE.
WE COME HERE WITH THE SUPPORT OF
OUR FAMILIES AND THE FAITH OF
OUR NEIGHBORS TO BE THEIR VOICE
IN WASHINGTON, FOR ALL THE WIVES
AND HUSBANDS, CHILDREN AND
PARENTS WHO ARE WATCHING OF
LOVED ONES TO BE SWORN IN, I
KNEW IT TOOK AN EXTRA COUPLE
DAYS.
I'LL BE HONEST, IT'S NOT HOW I
HAD IT PLANNED.
I WANT YOU TO REMEMBER THIS
MOMENT, TAKE IT IN.
YOUR LOVED ONES ARE ABOUT TO
MAKE HISTORY.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR UNDERSTANDING AND YOUR
SACRIFICE, AND WE WILL WORK
EVERY DAY TO MAKE YOU PROUD.
MY MOST FAVORITE SPOT IN THIS
BUILDING IS NOT IN THIS CHAMBER,
IT'S IN THE CHAMBER WE MET
BEFORE, IN STATUARY HALL.
IT'S MY FAVORITE PLACE TO TAKE
PEOPLE ON A TOUR.
YOU SEE, IT'S WHERE ABRAHAM
LINCOLN SERVED.
JUST A ONE-TERM CONGRESSMAN, SAT
IN THE BACK.
I LIKE TO GO TO THAT SPOT AND I
LIKE TO STAND WHERE HE STOOD.
I LIKE TO DO IT AT NIGHT WHEN
PEOPLE AREN'T AROUND.
I LIKE TO LOOK OVER AND LOOK AT
THE CLOCK BECAUSE THAT'S THE
SAME CLOCK AND SAME VIEW THAT
ABRAHAM LINCOLN SAW.
I'VE WATCHED LINCOLN SERVE IN
THE GREATEST CHALLENGE TO OUR
CONSTITUTION, THE CIVIL WAR.
I WATCHED HIM TAKE PEOPLE WHO
WERE RIVALS AND PUT THEM
TOGETHER.
I WATCHED AT A TIME HE DID NOT
KNOW IT THAT A NATION COULD
SUSTAIN ITSELF, BUT HE DREAMT OF
A FUTURE AND BUILT A RAILROAD
ACROSS THE NATION.
I WANT US TO ALL TAKE A MOMENT
ONE TIME THAT YOU WERE HERE.
I WANT YOU TO STAND THERE.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK, AND I WANT
YOU TO THINK IF AMERICA COULD DO
IT THEN, WE CAN DO IT NOW ONE
MORE TIME.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ABRAHAM LINCOLN GAVE HIS LIFE IN
SERVICE TO THIS COUNTRY.
ONE OF HIS MOST IMPORTANT
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT AMERICA
APPLIES TODAY AS MUCH AS IT DID
160 YEARS AGO.
HE SAID WE ARE STRIVING TO
MAINTAIN THE GOVERNMENT AND
INSTITUTIONS OF OUR FATHERS AND
TO TRANSMIT THEM TO OUR CHILDREN
AND OUR CHILDREN'S CHILDREN
FOREVER.
MY FELLOW AMERICANS, THAT IS
STILL OUR MISSION TODAY.
THIS MOMENT CALLS FOR RESTORING
TRUST WITHIN OUR COUNTRY AND
WITH EACH OTHER.
IN THAT SPIRIT I WILL WORK WITH
ANYONE AND EVERYONE WHO SHARES
OUR PASSION TO DELIVER A BETTER
FUTURE FOR THE NATION.
I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME.
AS A CONGRESS WE CAN ONLY
OPERATE IF WE COOPERATE.
MY DOOR WILL BE OPEN.
I'D LIKE YOU TO COME BY.
I WANT YOU TO SEE AS YOU WALK
DOWN THE HALL A LARGE PORTRAIT
OF LINCOLN.
I WANT YOU TO GO INTO THAT
CONFERENCE ROOM, AND I WANT YOU
TO SEE ANOTHER PORTRAIT.
MY MEMBERS KNOW OF THIS.
IT'S OF WASHINGTON CROSSING THE
DELAWARE.
YOU ALL KNOW THE STORY.
IT HAPPENED ON CHRISTMAS 1776.
THERE WAS NO iPHONE TO TAKE A
PICTURE.
PEOPLE WONDER WHEN IT WAS
PAINTED.
IT WASN'T PAINTED BY SOMEONE WHO
WAS THERE.
IT WAS PAINTED IN 1850 AND 1851.
HE WAS AN IMMIGRANT WHO LIVED IN
AMERICA.
YOU KNOW WHY HE PAINTED IT?
BECAUSE HE KNEW AMERICA WAS MORE
THAN A COUNTRY.
AMERICA WAS AN IDEA.
HE WENT HOME TO GERMANY, AND HE
WANTED GERMANY TO HAVE A
REVOLUTION BASED UPON THE VALUES
AND FREEDOMS THAT WE DEFEND
EVERY DAY.
HIS TALENT WAS ART, SO HE
BELIEVED IF HE PAINTED THIS
PAINTING HE COULD INSPIRE HIS
COUNTRYMEN TO RISE UP FOR THE
IDEA OF FREEDOM.
MANY HISTORIANS WILL TELL YOU HE
DIDN'T GET IT CORRECT.
THEY'LL TELL YOU WASHINGTON
CROSSED ON A DURHAM BOAT, BUT HE
PAINTS IT WITH WASHINGTON IN A
ROW BOAT.
YOU SEE 13 PEOPLE BUT ONLY 12
FACES.
YOU SEE WASHINGTON STANDING UP
IN A ROW BOAT IN THE MIDDLE OF
WINTER WEARING A CEREMONIAL
UNIFORM WITH HIS HAND ON HIS
CHEST, HE LOOKS SO STOIC.
YOU WOULD LOOK AT THAT MAN AND
YOU'D SAY I'D FOLLOW HIM
ANYWHERE.
YOU PROBABLY BELIEVE THAT HE
NEVER LOST THE BATTLE.
BUT HISTORY WOULD TELL US AT
THAT MOMENT, AT THAT TIME HE'D
ONLY LOST.
WE HAD NEVER WON.
YOU SEE, THAT WAS THE NIGHT OF
OUR FIRST VICTORY AS A NATION
WHEN WE SURPRISED THE HESSIANS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
PAINTING DON'T LOOK AT
WASHINGTON.
I WANT YOU TO LOOK AT WHO'S IN
THE BOAT.
YOU SEE, THE SECOND ROW IN THE
BU RAY HE'S SCOTTISH.
THE SECOND PERSON ACROSS HIM IN
THE GREEN ROWING THE EXACT SAME
CADENCE IS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN.
YOU COME DOWN RIGHT TO THE
MIDDLE, IN THE RED, THE PERSON
WHO'S ROWING THE STRONGEST IS A
WOMAN.
AND IN THE VERY BACK IS A
NATIVE-AMERICAN.
I DON'T KNOW FROM A HISTORIC
FACT IF THEY WERE IN THE BOAT
THAT NIGHT, BUT TO THIS YOUNG
IMMIGRANT WHO HAD LIVED IN
AMERICA, THAT'S WHO HE BELIEVED
WOULD BE IN THE BOAT.
THE SECOND TO LAST PERSON IS A
FARMER.
HE COULD BE FROM BAKERSFIELD.
I'M NOT SURE.
HIS HAND GOES ACROSS HIS FACE.
PEOPLE WILL DEBATE THIS PART,
BUT WHAT I SEE IS A HAND OF THE
13th PERSON NOBODY SEES.
YOU SEE WHAT I BELIEVE EMMANUEL
IS SAYING IS HERE WE ARE
BATTLING FOR THE CREATION OF THE
IDEA OF FREEDOM, THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL IS EQUAL, NOT A
PERFECT NATION BUT STRIVING TO
BE A MORE PERFECT UNION, HAVING
LOST EVERY BATTLE AGAINST THE
GREATEST CHALLENGE WITH THE
STRONGEST NATION, HAVING LOST
THEM ALL BUT WILLING TO DO IT ON
OUR HOLIEST OF NIGHTS WITH A
HAND REACHED OUT AND ASKING IF
YOU WOULD JOIN US.
THAT'S AS TRUE TODAY AS IT WAS
THEN.
IF WE LET EVERYBODY IN THE BOAT,
IF WE ROW IN THE SAME CADENCE
TOGETHER, THERE IS NO OBSTACLE
THIS BODY CAN OVERCOME FOR THIS
NATION.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT IS TIME FOR US TO BE THE
VOICE AND WORTHY OF THEIR VOTE.
LET ME CLOSE WITH THIS.
I MAY NOT KNOW ALL OF YOU.
SOME OF YOU ARE NEW, BUT I HOPE
ONE THING IS CLEAR AFTER THIS
WEEK.
I NEVER GIVE UP.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I MAKE THIS PROMISE.
I'LL NEVER GIVE UP FOR YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND I WILL NEVER GIVE UP ON
KEEPING OUR COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
OUR NATION IS WORTH FIGHTING
FOR.
OUR RIGHTS ARE WORTH FIGHTING
OUR DREAMS ARE WORTH FIGHTING
FOR.
OUR FUTURE IS WORTH FIGHTING
THEREFORE, WITH LOVE FOR THIS
COUNTRY AND CHARITY FOR EACH
OTHER, LET US NOW TAKE OUR OATH
AND BE WORTHY OF THE OFFICE